pop
[Musique]
je suis d'autant plus heureux de vous
présenter maintenant samson françois et
qu'il me rappelle une petite anecdote
gentille
lorsque j'étais étudiant quartier latin
j'avais un de mes camarades qui habitait
un hôtel de la rue monsieur le prince et
j'allais souvent lui rendre visite et
nous étions à l'accès à la fois
enthousiasmé ravi car il y avait un
enfant prodige dans cet hôtel qui jouait
du piano et qui nous ravit c'est à
chaque fois que j allais on passait des
heures à l'écouter
je crois d'ailleurs que tous les
habitants de l'hôtel contrairement à
quelques fois des gens qui se plaignent
mais tout le monde était ravi de
l'écouté et ce pianiste c'était samson
françois que j'ai retrouvé aujourd'hui
et je suis ravi de vous le présenter
d'abord parce que je l'estimé je le
tiens pour un des grands pianistes
d'aujourd'hui et il va nous présenter il
va nous faire entendre
deux morceaux de ravel qui sont parmi
les déserts que j'adore notamment
gaspard de la nuit qui vraiment pousse
la technique pianistique à un point
extraordinaire on pensait que liste
avait été de haut plus loin de la
difficulté je crois que ravel avec des
stars de la nuit est allé encore plus
loin
vous allez donc entendre gaspard de la
nuit que samson françois vient
d'enregistrer et aussi le tombeau de
couperin qui est en quelque sorte un
hommage à la musique française du xviiie
siècle et aussi qui était en même temps
un hommage à ses camarades disparus au
cours de la guerre de 1914 1918
[Musique]
en
ans
barbara une chanteuse de la rive gauche
disent les programmes et je m'excuse
mais il voyait surtout aucune allusion
politique mais je n'aime pas beaucoup
cette définition de chanteuses rive
gauche tout chanteuse rive droite
je pense qu'il y a les chanteurs qui ont
du talent et ceux qui n'en n'ont pas et
barbara elle a beaucoup de talent et je
suis content de présenter barbara et je
suis content de faire sa connaissance
aussi car je ne la connaissais pas
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai fait sa
connaissance l'autre jour grâce à la
télévision vous savez nous n'avons guère
le temps de sortir et dire le temps
d'aller au spectacle et madeleine renaud
a fait installer dans sa loge au théâtre
du palais royal
un appareil de télévision si bien que
entre les actes entre les scènes nous
rebondissons dans la loge de madrid pour
aller voir la télévision et c'est comme
ça que l'autre jour nous avons eu
l'occasion nous étions cinq ou six dans
cette loge à découvrir barbara qui
vraiment nous a absolument enthousiasmé
je suis donc ravi de vous la présenter
et comme elle vient d'enregistrer
récemment un disque je vais lui demander
de nous chanter une de ses chances
[Musique]
oh
la paix l'amour avec un homme grand
comme paris toi ton avant tu mens promet
du mans promet et moi j'attends dantec
inquiète de voir s'allumer lecron
refaire
la paix l'amour dont je rêvais la paix
l'amour donc tu causes est quand tu
avais pense que tu voulais
[Musique]
la paix l'amour au fond des yeux ou sa
meute à pisseleux karembeu la paix
l'amour à même la peau quand il fait
froid ça vous dit la paix l'amour à
mourir pour ça ressemble un peu à un
sourire c'est tellement cheval y penser
volée
[Musique]
il n'est jamais venu à l'idée on aurait
pu vraiment c'est mais avec du soleil à
blaye bras et puis des rires à coeur
joie
c'était pourtant pas bien malins dit
avec un oeil reprendre la main alors on
aurait plus payer la belle amour entre
rêve et savez comme bien souvent j'ai
pensé à [ __ ] le camp pour aller
chercher cet amour qui ont été mes nuits
et mes jours et puis je me suis fait une
raison
j'ai pas lens et metz illusion
la paix l'amour avec un an une grande
comme paris
j'en aurai pas
[Musique]
de belles amours
nous entamons
[Musique]
paul verlaine dit par françois périer
rené guy cadou dit par daniel gélin
charles baudelaire divergent desailly
apollinaire dit par jacques dubé et
charles péguy dit par pierre vaneck
pierre vaneck qui vient d'obtenir un
très grand succès personnel dans la
représentation des possédés d'albert
camus d'après dostoïevski qui est une
entreprise que nous sommes heureux de
saluer ici pour le grand succès qu'elle
vient d'avoir pierre vaneck va nous dire
de charles péguy la présentation de
paris à notre-dame étoile de la mer
voici la lourde nef où nous ramons tout
nu sous vos commandement voici notre
détresse et nos désarmement voici le
quai du louvre et l'éclusé le bief
voici notre appareil et voici notre chef
c'est un gars de chez nous qui sifflent
par moment il n'a pas son pareil pour
les gouvernements il a la tête dure
le geste un peu bref règne qui vous
lever sur tous les océans vous penserez
à nous quand nous serons au large
aujourd'hui c'est le jour d'embarquer
notre charge
voici l'énorme grue et les longs meubles
mans s'il fallait le chargé de nos
pauvres vertu ce vaisseau s'en irait
vers votre auguste seuil plus creux que
la noisette
après que l'écureuil la laisser retomber
de ses ongles pointu nul ballot
n'entrerait par les panneaux béant et
nous arriverions dans la mer de
sargasses traînant c'est inutile et
grotesque carcasses et les anglais
diraient ils n'ont rien mis dedans mais
nous saurons l'emplir et nous vous le
juron il sera le plus beau dans cette
illustre port la cargaison ira jusque
sur le plat bord
et quand il sera plein nous le
couronneront nous nous chargerons pas
notre pauvre maïs mais de l'or et du blé
que nous en porterons
et il tiendra la mer car nous le
chargeront du poids de nos péchés payé
par votre fils
[Musique]
dans la ville décimé d'hiroshima les
peuples du monde entier se sont réunis
pour reconstruire une église et c'est un
jour à cette église que will and kate
s'est rendu pour enregistrer un disque
d'orgue
il a choisi des morceaux de jean
sébastien bach
[Musique]
à
on
de rené oiseaux et bob castella chansons
nouvelles qui a pour titre la fête à
loulou qu'est ce qui ne va pas dis moi
la vie on dirait vraiment
ok tu nous fuit nous sommes des copains
4 on travaillait mais après le boulot tu
ne dis plus jamais rien caché la graine
du beurre en petits cubes si t'as de la
veine tu y vas tu
nous faisons pas manquer chez la tante
agathe en compagnie gros il y aura du
coup les douches et d'au-delà tard était
plus du bourgeon tu verras nenets et
quelques heures en mode tout neuf et
honnête c'est un vrai trésor et sait-on
jamais peut-être 4l ou près des projets
hier avec moi
écoutez avec une une émission de disques
ne pouvait pas se faire sans que nous
ayons avec nous livre montand qui nous
souhaite bonne chance parce que
indiscutablement yves montand c'est dans
ce domaine la perfection son tour de
chant récemment son récital au théâtre
de l'étoile l'a prouvé s'il fallait
encore le prouver
c'est vraiment la perfection du champ de
la variété aussi bien dans la
chansonnette raven comics gay dans le
champ gramat tic
je suis très heureux yves que tu sois
venu avec nous aujourd'hui et il ya une
chose que je voulais te demander parce
que je pense que ça intéresse pas mal de
spectateurs c'est de savoir qu'est ce
que tu préfères au point de vue
enregistrements de disques elle est la
formule du prêt vert est ce que tu
préfères enregistré en studio ou est ce
que tu préfères l'enregistrement public
comme ça l'air de se faire beaucoup
maintenant
non je trouve que il est beaucoup plus
préférable de faire ça en public parce
que peut-être on peut améliorer
davantage en studio et grand public qui
a tout de même l'artiste voyez est
obligé d'y aller c'est à dire que le
public est l'un et il faut répondre aux
exigences du public exact il ya une
vérité une sincérité que l'on perd
malheureusement studio moi je trouve
mais par contre on peut techniquement le
soigner davantage en studio je voyais
bien sûr ouais bien sûr c'est à choisir
je prendrais plutôt quel que soit le
disque quand cela se passe
face au public mais il ya tout de même
un contact avec le public qui est
inquiète indispensable pour la qualité
d'une chanson et mais comment cela se
passe-t-il alors est ce que on
enregistre une fois pour toutes on est
ce qu'on fait plusieurs enregistre
nombre mais ils font venir tout le
matériel d'enregistrement des voitures
on avertit pas le public n'ont même pas
dans la confidence mais on a vu crois
que c'est une émission différé alors on
enregistre pure on écoute et puis bon
sur 24 chansons par exemple comme c'est
mon cas - par exemple bien il se peut
très bien qui en est une où une ou deux
qui n'a pas très bien été jugé hier que
j'ai pressé le mouvement ou que j'ai eu
même peut-être un petit couac les bleus
n'ont pas souvent mais enfin ça peut
arriver
alors dans ces cas là on recommence
l'enregistrement se dire que deux
chansons en question qui ont été faibles
en général ça prendre deux trois jours
bien entendu on sort en quelque sorte
c'est un écrémage on a ce qu'il ya mieux
d'yves montand en achetant de liste mais
je vous souhaite un fait indiscutable et
bien ivre je suis très content et je te
souhaite bonne chance je sais que tu vas
partir bien
en tournée oui à travers le monde et oui
eh bien je te souhaite bonne chance je
suis sûr que les publics du monde entier
ratifieront notre notre opinion yves
montand est numéro un du music hall
français que toi gentil
[Musique]
une panique dans le monde du disque on a
l'air de tenir une nouvelle marche du
pont de la rivière kwaï chaque maison de
disques à un ou plusieurs
enregistrements aux sorties ou à sortir
et plusieurs versions différentes pour
les paroles de chacun pourra faire très
largement mais très largement son choix
et bien l'auberge de 6e bonheur est un
film qui vient de sortir et dont la
vedette principale est ingrid bergman
qui joue là un rôle extrêmement émouvant
d'une américaine de pendant la guerre
sino-japonaise
il se dévoue entièrement qui se consacre
aux enfants chinois
elle parvient à faire passer les lignes
japonaise à toute une équipe d'enfants
chinois qu'elle a sa garde
le personne n'y croit tout le monde est
persuadé qu elle n'y parviendra pas et
cependant grâce à des indications de
paysans elle elle arrive à trouver des
chemins inconnus
elle passe à travers les lignes
accompagné de ses petits ensembles et
finalement elle arrive triomphalement à
la ville nous tout le monde est sidéré
de la voir arriver avec cette idée
n'était qu'à six jours de ça mais
c'était il ya presque deux semaines
les montagnes qui traverse ont contrôlé
par l'ennemi est à peu près un
franchisseur je sais mais ils n'ont
pratiquement aucune chance de s'en
sortir
je sais bien tout le monde en ville le
sait c'est pour ça que nous priions
nuitées jour pour ces enfants que nous
continuerons à prier et attendre excusez
moi docteur mer
elle aa
[Musique]
j'ai tous les enfants les enfants les
voient la fed en fin d'été chaud
[Applaudissements]
thomas
et
[Musique]
et non mais
ryan
m
[Musique]
et
ma vie
[Musique]
il
ban
[Musique]
agen
[Applaudissements]
c'était discorama une émission de denise
glaser et pierre brive réalisation jean
kersch bron avec la collaboration de
jean desailly et samson françois barbara
pierre vaneck yves montand et les petits
écoliers chantants de bondy
[Musique]